Глина дуже чуттєва до нашого душевного стану.
Спокій приходить. Просто ти занурюєшся в процес
і на деякий час забуваєш про все.
У такому житті ми поспішаємо,
у нас дуже, дуже швидке життя,
і ми не встигаємо вирішити якісь
душевні глибинні питання.
А тут можна  у спокої думати про ті речі,
на які у нас не вистачає часу.
Зазирнути в себе...
Займаюся я керамікою і програмуванням.
Процеси тут відбуваються суто керамічні.
Я працюю з гончарним колом або з пластами глини.
Роблю різні керамічні вироби...
Тут проводжу майстер-класи з дітками і з дорослими.
Вироби, які я роблю, розходяться по Україні і в інші країни.
Через інтернет отримую замовлення.
Отак вони мандрують світом.
Мені дали гончарне коло, трохи глини,
і з цього почалося все.
Раз не вийшло, два [рази] не вийшло,
25 [раз] не вийшло...
Дивлюсь відео: сіли люди раз там,
два, за раз горщик, раз — що хочеш.
Сідаю я — нічого! Ну сайт я можу зробити,
чому я не можу горщик?
Тобто це ж просто, була впертість така,
як треба ж, взялася.
Так пішло діло, навчилася і потім зрозуміла,
що я вже без цього не можу.
Гончарство — це така хвороба, в гарному сенсі.
Коли ти працюєш за колом,
то спокій приходить такий.
Відходить роздратованість і нервові моменти.
Для мене ремесла народні
всі важливі і вони йдуть від душі.
Це відчуття глини, просто відчуваєш, що треба робити.
От якийсь такий момент приходить.
Це у нас з 2014 року. Ми у 2014 році виїхали.
Я взяла сина і виїхала з Криму.
В Херсоні ми опинилися. Вирішили приїхати сюди.
Там в мене були батьки: мама й тато,
ми вирішили, ну вони вже старенькі,
але ми вирішили, що треба вивозити просто Тимура, сина мого.
Він мав піти в школу, в перший клас, і просто не хотілося,
щоб дитина виросла в брехні.
То забрала Тимура і ми поїхали з ним до Львова.
Потім якось так сталося, що нам запропонували люди
з Нововолинська в них теж побути, перебути якийсь час.
І там Тимур пішов до школи в перший клас.
Але Волинь, там через клімат він почав хворіти.
Він же кримчанин такий, йому треба сухо, тепло.
І ми вирішили — повернемося трошки ближче.
Ми ще сподівалися, що все закінчиться,
ми ж думали — це не довго,
трошки так місяць, пів року, ну рік.
То ми чекали, що ми повернемося додому,
що Україна повернеться.
Приїхали сюди, але не зовсім у Херсон.
Ми були рік ще в Голій Пристані.
Там я і познайомилася з гончарством.
Коли переживали цей переїзд і взагалі
життя спочатку і важко емоційно,
психологічно дуже було важко —
мене врятувала глина.
Від депресії, від просто такого відчуття,
що ти не знаєш, що тобі робити.
Глина дуже допомогла: якби знаходиш сили, знаходиш себе.
Я вдячна і не хочу кидати,
тому що буде важко без неї.
Для мене буде важко.
Є таке сучасне, модне слово — арт-терапія.
От якраз це — глина:
тактильні відчуття і бачиш результат.
Ти надаєш форму, ти робиш те, що хочеться,
те що відчувають твої руки, відчуває душа.
А потім ще і розмальовуєш, тут колір ще грає.
Я відчула на собі цю дію глини,
як вона лікує, спокій з'являється, і думаю:
«Так, треба людям віддавати.»
Завжди в житті не тільки треба брати, ще й віддавати.
Ось це перша ідея, яка прийшла в голову, —
проводити майстер-класи.
І ми почали з дітками з аутизмом, вони почали приходити,
працювати.
Вони роблять чудові речі.
Я запитала мам: «Якщо ви не проти,
якщо ми зробимо виставку робіт діток,
які з аутизмом працюють з глиною?»
Мами підтримали, обіцяли зберігати всі роботи.
Приходять на майстер-класи ще і дорослі, але їх менше.
— Здравствуйте
— Добрий день!
Запрошую вас на майстер-клас з гончарства.
Діти завжди готові пробувати щось нове.
І вони не соромляться, вони не думають,
що вийде, не вийде.
А у дорослих вже є така установка — має вийти, але не вийде.
Тому я не сяду, не буду нічого робити, воно ж не вийде.
Що робити пам'ятаєте?
— Поїхали.
— Давайте. Що перше робимо?
— Ні, ви дєлаєте.
— Розказую. А я ні, робите ви.
— Гончар, гончар ви. Я просто...
— Я вам розкажу. Добре, спочатку треба приклеїти
шматочок глини до кола...
Дорослі більше вагаються, більше думають.
Потім все ж таки вони пробують
і вже потім розуміють, що це не страшно.
Ніхто не оцінює, ніхто не каже — вийшло, не вийшло.
Тобто людина робить свою творчу
таку роботу, вкладає свою душу.
Зараз витягну, подивимося, що в нас вийшло.
Ці вироби пройшли два випали.
Цей перший випал завжди проходить глина,
щоб твердий стан у неї став.
А другий, я покрила матовою прозорою,
потім нанесла малюнок,
і покрила матовою прозорою поливкою.
Десь випалюється десять годин перший раз
і близько дев'яти годин другий раз.
Ну це моє улюблене різьблення —
вирізається глина, залишаються малюнки.
Тут два типи поливи: матова така,
і поверхня залишається така шероховата, і глянцева поливка тут.
Бувало так, що хотілося все кинути,
тому що програмістом бути легше: ноутбук і все.
А тут ти не тільки крутиш глину, ти ще й вантажником
працюєш, і електриком, бо треба з пічкою...
Щось там сталося, ти маєш розбиратися в цьому.
Але це така закоханість.
Я намагаюся зовсім вже не
займатися програмуванням.
Я не беру замовлень на сайти.
Не хочу...
Ну кавуни — це херсонська тема...
Тут була підтримка людей дуже така тепла.
І тому для нас Херсон є теплим містом.
Місто, де я вже стала керамістом,
де в нас з'явилися друзі.
Україна — це свобода,
це можливість робити те, що ти хочеш.
Там ти нічого не можеш вирішувати,
там за тебе вирішили все: сиди, живи.
Як мені кримчани казали:
«Ви там дихаєте повітрям свободи».
Оце відчуття: ти можеш вільно дихати,
ти можеш думати, що ти хочеш, ти можеш казати, що ти хочеш.
Оце в нас є і це дуже важливо.
Просто можливість жити.